because there was only one person in the
world that was sandy and that was olivia
and john john travolta pays tribute to
his beloved greece co-star
sandy
olivia newton-john died on monday she
was 73 years old
john mourns his friend of over 40 years
on social media writing my dearest
olivia you made all of our lives so much
better your impact was incredible i love
you so much we will see you down the
road and we will all be together again
yours from the first moment i saw you
and forever your danny your john
this is the jacket this i've maintained
we won't talk about the pants
john and olivia's legacies are bound
forever by their classic roles as danny
and sandy
they had brought up linda ronstadt
they'd brought up marie osmond
and i said
they're wonderful i said but every guy
in the world wants olivine and john is
their
girlfriend right and i knew that because
i wanted that i
felt the same way
okay and every girl wants to be like her
and i said if you don't see this
you guys are nuts because there was only
one person in the world that was sandy
and that was olivia and john
[Music]
they later reunited on screen in 1983's
two of a kind
oh you sound excited would you like to
watch yeah
it's hard to put a finger on it i guess
a chemistry and you can't explain a
chemistry whatever that is i think we
really like each other and we it was
just something that happened it's like
an
energy thing there's definitely an
energy thing and it and i've analyzed it
sometimes i think sometimes it has to do
with similar backgrounds like really
even though you're from australia and
england your monetary background your
your visions of your career identical to
mine and
sort of that
we have the same approach towards life
that same sort of love of life the two
were lifelong friends
sharing some of their favorite memories
with e.t over the years
we didn't even need to know each other
the chemistry was actually from the
first like screen testing we did at work
[Music]
sandy
tell me about it
i always think of the minute that i
came out as sandy too as being
kind of exciting even on the day all
that was just i it was a natural
reaction you know it was so much fun to
see her dressed up in that garb you know
and that that number like doing that
number was great fun
[Music]
it was really hot it was really hot in
that uh gym yeah
but it was uh but we had a bowl i mean
the whole movie
[Music]
i think it's just amazing to be in a
movie that's a classic i mean it's been
popular it seems like every year from
then i've heard someone talk about
greece how they love it or their
children love it all their grandchildren
love it and they watch it on tape at
least once a week it's just incredible i
feel very lucky it feels like we've
given a gift
to
mankind somehow you know around the
world
and that feels uh so so honorable i
think don't you
yeah it feels like you've contributed
something